Matt is with us in Baton Rouge hi Matt
how are you Dave what about yourself
better than I deserve what's up how can
I help
Hey so I am planning on proposing I'm 23
years old playing on proposing in the
next six to eight months and so my
question is should I stop putting the
way stop putting extra on top of my note
on my truck note and an extra 200
dollars a month is what I'm putting
towards my truck note should I stop
putting that towards my truck note and
put that aside just to buy a ring cash
in the next six to eight months or
should I keep on adding that 200 extra
Amash towards my note and then finance
the ring whenever I get to that may june
july no i'm so your goal is to be out of
that and to get married right yes okay
if your goal is to be out of debt the
first step to being out of debt is never
borrow again right and so that means
that you would slow your debt reduction
on your truck enough to save to buy the
ring and so what do you make a month or
a year right now each stick of 1373 so
it's about 2,800 a month take home okay
all right that's net and what are you
thinking of spending on the ring okay
good yeah 3,000 your max budget one
months one month's income is enough on a
ring okay there's no correlation between
the size of the diamond and the success
of the marriage all right matter of fact
there might be an inverse correlation
it's at some point that could be so the
but you know that's neither here nor
there but the thing is and then the last
the second thing is you have dad mom
somebody in your life that buys diamonds
occasionally no
diamonds are like furniture they're some
of the largest markup items on the
planet and so learn a little bit about
it as you're getting ready to buy it
learn not to become a diamond expert
where you have to grade them or
something like that I'm not trying to
get you to be an appraiser but learn
just a little bit about it and then you
can shop with something like a diamond
broker maybe even a pawn shop and have
that have you know take it have it
appraised that kind of a thing but
you're looking for a deal
you really are instead of walking into
the mall jewelry store which is the
highest markup item on the planet now
there are some hometown jewelry stores
that do a good job that might be an
exception but you know your classic
chains and that kind of stuff man you
you know you just for the money you're
spending you could have got twice as
much right if you'd learn a little bit
slow the payment on the note yes an
order to save up in order to save up
your - Glynis I every every time you got
ten months of having ten months of 200
bucks is your $2,000 right right yeah
and and anything else you can squeeze
out now I mean the faster you save that
up the faster you get back to paying off
the truck what do you owe on your truck
okay cool
only be nice to knock a bunch of that
out - in the process but I'd like for
you to crank this up even higher and go
ahead and knock that out even more you
know but but yeah before I would I would
never borrow again which means the only
way to buy a ring is save up for it
which means that you're gonna slow down
probably the truck in order to get there
and that that's what you're looking at
so hey thanks for the call